hello and welcome to this video playing
hamurapi
hamurapi i know hamurabi
from
the civilization franchise
let's stroll back knight d4 is actually
a very reasonable move
okay
that should be pretty nice for why damn
what is this
knight coming to c7
long long journey to um
not really great square but still of
course this is playable for black it's
not
like he's um lost or anything it's just
a good benoni
for white okay um we can go a5 here or
simply say that b5 isn't a threat anyway
i think this is always tough to say both
scenarios are probably good for white
some went with this
yeah this is always also again this is
an interesting moment
you can take or you can avoid the
capture
and just say okay um it's it's good
anyway
hmm that's interesting actually
interesting question
the move before would be great to get in
if i do get that in black is
basically falling apart so it's fairly
important
knight a4 bishop d2 is one way to do it
i don't know i mean not like
you play the move quickly before but you
get to prepare it
yeah and he will play knight h5
something like that
knight a8 okay so
prepare before
so i get before in just like that
okay
knight f4 i can take that's not a
problem
well okay he's going going in a
different
direction in this in this way
i cannot take f4 as the bishop could be
on b4
but again that is not a problem
the only thing that slightly concerns me
is the time
i've as
often spent a bit
much time
so just open this up
okay that's an interesting reply
actually if i take and then
he can take with the pawn
so i probably have to move this again
not a problem really but interesting
knight f4 knight f4 i will take
i don't mind that
so and now i thought i thought c6 should
be good but
it's not the only option let's see six
is just giving me a really tremendous
pawn
i just wonder if he can take and play
knight and queen to b5 this is a very
strange
situation because i cannot take
okay well this is
well this is i used to take with the
pawn
this this
rook b1 i can t
i can take f4 here
um
yeah that's pretty difficult
here with this time situation
yes b2 rook a8 rook a1
well i can take d6 and have the c pawn
okay so
i have no time at all
i would be okay with the draw with four
seconds on the clock
i have no clue what the position is like
yeah i mean this is a bit wimpy maybe
but
yeah four seconds position i don't know
i mean i was totally winning for sure
that's not a question really because
this is
entirely anti-positional from start to
finish
like this is already strategically
pretty much awful
so but i'm not sure about the final
position i didn't see a clear way
forward
so this is unsurprisingly um given by
winning by the engine
but i was so slow
in putting this on the board so bishop
e3
yeah queen b3 is stronger
this is many things are good here i
guess c6 this is actually
i expected that that could be a
controversial move because
it gets his knight into the game
by exchanging queen b3 is actually a lot
stronger
something like that is very clearly good
because
i will probably just win the a pawn
and then the d pawn is fantastically
strong in this situation when he does
not have a passer a passer b
passer the bishop on g7 is actually a
bad piece because it's pointing into
absolutely nothing
and that's it's great and this way the
way it
it turned out um okay taking and queen
d2
is is winning but okay let's see what i
did is probably also winning but
yeah the time was just too bad this
this queen c1 is better
or g3 yeah so ultimately it turns out
that the pawn is not as dangerous
and this is a bit yeah i suspected that
it is wimpy
oh queen e3 i could have seen yeah
that's not that is actually
pretty simple yeah attacking this twice
and if he has to trade queens uh
something
along these lines here is pretty strong
i think
e5 is actually strong okay
i thought that this is good enough for a
large advantage which
probably is but e5 is better yeah of
course
you you simply
get to promote your pawns so yeah
unsurprisingly i had much more than this
draw but
the the slow uh pace was
getting to me i mean he was dashing out
all his moves instantly so
sometimes the problem okay guys thanks
for watching